hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game but before we check out the
game I would just like to thank everyone
for joining the stream yesterday for
joining delicious arena there were over
6,000 players so it's a record for this
channel are really just a wonderful
event and for those of you who weren't
able to follow the stream but have
entered the giveaway I have put a list
of all the ten people who want to give
away and the list will be in the
description below at the end so to check
it out if you by any chance one just
contact me we are either via email via
any social network and we will arrange
how how I will present you with the
prize now getting back to this game it's
a 15 year old Gary Kasparov against
American Grand Master Simon Pilate the
game was played in 1978 in Doug appeals
in Latvia and it's just a wonderful
attacking game now I have a series of
books and world champions they are very
short not really book it's more of a
booklet or something but it's really
short and it's sort of a compilation of
best games by every world champion and
in the one about Garry Kasparov this
game is the first game in the book and
ever since I saw this game when I first
started playing chess and then I was
like looking ok there's this defense
there's this defense there's this attack
there are gambits I found the ahem
defense and then I saw of course the the
four pawns attack against the alien
defense and I thought that was the best
way to go about it and that is the main
weapon against the aliens defense but
then after I saw this game it really
impressed me and I found a different
line that I liked even more and ever
since I saw this game I started playing
this line against aliens and perhaps if
you enjoy it you might also start
employing it in your own games so
without further ado let's check out this
very nice game Casper has the white
pieces and he opens with efore at this
time of course Casper was still not
world champion as the game was played in
1978 and at that time of course Anatoly
Karpov was world champion but ok night
we have six aliens defenses on the board
with with E 5 just challenging the
knight Knight to d5 d 4 and D 6 and here
when I only started learning about chess
I I knew that you can
f-4c for creative for phone pong for him
in the center and just you know play it
that way but here was the first time I
saw the nice to f3 move and I was very
interested why not immediately go f4 so
your night it doesn't block the pond but
you know if power play that of course I
was very interested in it black
continues with g6 with Bishop to c4
giving away the night and night to b6
challenging the bishop and now Bishop to
b3 if you're if you have this position
in wood you can even try the Bishop
captures on f7 9 g5 in e6 even though
it's not really all that great for white
you will be able to win a lot of bullet
points with this idea and here Apple I
think went a 5 and this is the this is
the same position that Boris possibly
had a bit against Bobby Fischer in their
1972 World Chess Championship match and
Spassky went for the immediate Bishop to
g7 if you haven't seen this game on my
channel if you want to subscribe when we
were covering the Bobby Fischer saga I
will put a link to that game in the
description below it will be the first
thing you will see if you want to check
that out as well to see how Fischer
handles this position with the black
pieces but here we have a 5x7 politic we
have a 4 by Kasparov not allowing a 4 by
black and a now Bishop to g7 and here
Knight to g5 taking advantage of the
undefended pawn on f7 and preparing f4
and the knight will then not go back to
f3 denied will go to e4 and from E 4 it
will be a very strong piece so first
East 6 taking care of the deep threat on
the f7 square we have f4 and now comes D
captures on e5 with pawn captures on e5
and now c5 challenging white strong
center and here you could go c3 but
first Kasparov creates another threat
towards the f7 pawn you have to deal
with this and only after Pilate castles
Casper wins goes for c3 I just
strengthening the center with knight c6
developing adding another attacker
towards the d d4 pawn we have Knight to
e4 now and for me for the night is a
very strong piece going for d6 but also
for f6 I've black if Kasparov manages to
win blacks dark square
then there will be a lot of holes here
the cover end s Kasparov still has the
bishop pair it should be should be quite
a nice advantage so first Knight to d7
for the controlling the f6 square Bishop
to e3 developing a bishop also
protecting the d4 square one more time
and now Knight to e7
from there the knight can go to either
at d5 or f5 and Bishop to g5 now pinning
the night on e 7 we have seek after
Sunday for C chapters on d4 end now h6
by black now black now wants to unpin so
first brush up to h4 we have g5 by
politic and Bishop all the way to f2 now
with more protection towards the d4 pawn
and now Knight finally comes to g6 as
the the square opened up we have
Nightbeat the c3 back as part of
developing yet another night and now
Queen to e7 and here Bush up to see to
the bishop will be much more useful on
this diagonal as it is pretty we
diagonal this Knight is not on f6 this
night is on g6 so it makes this h7
square even weaker with b6 by black
maybe with ideas of fee and catering the
light square Bishop Bishop to e3 by
Kasparov and now comes a bishop to a6 by
moving Bishop to e3 that's part of read
some space for the rook so you can now
move it with rook to f2 and here you
have to decide what to do with black
black definitely prepared f5 but f5 goes
into a into a line that pretty much
forces white to end up with being a pawn
up in the endgame for example if F 5 you
can capture on a Sun and then after
Knight captures you can go d5 and here
after a series of trades Knight captures
captures captures and captures with
check King h8 now you will grab the b6
bone and here white is just up upon
black and place on Bishop to b7 attack
the Queen and here after Queen to b6 we
can just go into a long series of trades
captures Bishop can capture the rook
Bishop can capture on e4 Queen captures
here Knight captures and Bishop captures
and you get this position where your
rook is under attack rook c8 and the
game continues where white is up
on its it's a B to point so black does
have a lot of pressure against it but
white white should be better can pull
out and hold this against Kasparov well
I will never know as the position was
not reached so here instead of this f5
line plotnick played nice to h8 first
and it simply doesn't work so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
the move and why I enjoyed this game so
much I will give you a couple of seconds
if you want to decide whether to do it
or not for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations you are an
excellent finder of tactics i'm garry
kasparov birthday and for those of you
who just wanna enjoy a show here as we
said this diagonal is weak the queen is
also looking forward to coming over to
h5 maybe also threatening to come to h7
so bishop the captures on g5 a very nice
idea and you have to react it as your
queen is under attack so how do you
defend with h captures on g5 and now
Queen to h5 with ideas that
well if black does nothing you will get
some Knight f6 check ideas and then of
course after the knife moves and Knight
captures pawn captures and well Queen to
h7 will be will be deadly but here we
have f5 creating some room for the king
and also if Y doesn't react the bishop
is now blocked by the f5 point so of
course the casbah has to react Knight
captures and g5 is played again
threatening checkmate on h7 so we have
looked to f7 Kasparov already sacrificed
a piece so Pilate doesn't mind giving up
the rook to grab yet another piece but
of course Kasparov isn't interested here
casparo finds the best way to continue
this fierce attack and he sacrifices the
second bishop that's what's always nice
about having the bishop pair you can
always sacrifice both of your bishops
and it doesn't matter who what do you
capture it with with the pawn order look
whichever you captured with will freed
the d5 square for Kasparov tonight and
this is the point of Bishop captures on
f5 either you capture in the f5 Square
freeze immediately or you first grab it
with the rook which which happened in
the game
we have rook a person even f-5e captors
on i-5 and now just Knight to d5 and
here you can see even though black is up
material whites nights are really
impressive just covering a whole lot of
squares in front of the black King and
it's well the black just doesn't have
any useful moves here but I think did
play queen t8 he offered a trade of
Queens but of course as far as an
interest interested he sacrificed
material he wants to take this to an end
he played Queen to h7 with Czech we have
King to f8 and now comes Queen captures
on f5 a very important move it's not
about grabbing upon it's about freeing
the F file for the rook
so King goes back and now Queen back to
h7 King to f8 and now how do you bring
the rook into the game not rook to f1
because all of you saw that the bishop
on e6 is covering the f1 square but
rather a nice rook lift rook to a3 now
the rook is coming over to f3 and
there's no way for black to prevent this
here politic tried an active move rook
to c8 hoping for some checkmating ideas
which are possible for black if white
messes up cuz para went rook to f3 check
with Knight to f6 blocking and this was
politics idea if he captures on f6 then
of course rook to c1
well ends pretty badly for white as
Queen to e 1 will be checkmate the King
has nowhere to go so after Knight to f6
Kasparov simply makes room for Ace King
we have h3 and now comes Queen to g6 but
any move any other move isn't much
better but again for the second time in
this video feel free to pause it and
find the quickest way to end
Black's suffering I'll give you a couple
of seconds once again for you to decide
whether you want to do it or not as it
is a Saturday at least here in Croatia
so for those of you who were able to do
it once again congratulations finding
such nice tactics on a Saturday and also
on casbah Rose birthday you were an
excellent player and for those of you
who just wanna enjoy so rook captures on
f6 with check so how does black react
well you do have to capture the rook
otherwise you're going to lose the Queen
Bishop captures on f6 is played and now
of course knight c6 check
and you don't have all that many squares
King te8 was played and now here you
could still mess up for example if you
play something like Knight d2 c7 check
you might think it's the same but it's
not here black can just capture it and
after Knight captures King will attack
the knight and you don't have a
checkmate here you'll just have to go
back and forth and be very happy with a
perpetual as you are down material but
Casper of course did no such thing here
cuz power play Knight captures on f6
it's with check and now the King has
nowhere to go
the white knights are simply too
powerful and black has to give up the
Queen but Pilate did not give up the
Queen it was in this position that
seventh alot Nick resigned the game he
resigned because he loses the Queen and
after that there are no more tricks you
can give one check the king will higher
than h2 and now it's just all over well
the threat of checkmate is here once you
block it
check moves captures and now white is
just up too much material the position
is completely winning for white yeah
after Knight captures on f6 Samuel
Plotnik resigned the game and a very
nice victory for the 15 year-old Garry
Kasparov really a powerful attacking
game against the idea him defense so I
do hope you enjoyed it I remember when I
saw it I really enjoyed it and I've
tried to choose ideas III I've seen in
this game in my games against aliens
defense as I have faced it several times
in tournament playing classical chess
but also in blitz you can always go for
some nice ideas nice attacking ideas
that happened in this game yeah once
again that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Micky
Grammatik of Daniel Wilson Daniel DOMA
said Hank Tang Wang and Aristotle's the
Oliviera marquee for a conversion to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous videos sure
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content to check out to the
winners maybe you've won the giveaway
yesterday and also hyper interest to
check out Spassky vs. special game 13 to
see how Bobby Fischer handles this line
with the black pieces of the idea hands
defense
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your Saturday